[Музика]
добре, хлопці, ласкаво просимо назад, і сьогодні у нас
є підсумковий урок про велику в'язницю, тому
що це останній
урок про Великобританію
.  неможливо
добре, давайте подивимося, ми постараємося зробити все можливе,
добре, тому місце призначення все ще є
Великобританія, хлопці, ми просимо вас закрити
очі і уявити, що ви
подорожуєте однією з найкращих країн
світу, добре,
тому закрийте очі, слухайте  я і
подумай про свою ідеальну подорож до Сполученого
Королівства добре, ви готові,
тому, хлопці, закрийте очі і уявіть, що
ви в літаку, ви дивитеся
у вікно і бачите хмари,
літак прилітає в аеропорт, і ви відчуваєте
себе трохи  трохи нервуєш, коли приземлишся,
виходиш з літака і слідуєш за вказівниками, щоб
отримати свою валізу, ви отримуєте свою валізу
і виходите з аеропорту, ви
не можете повірити, що ви нарешті в Лондоні,
ви вирішили піти на таксі до свого
готель в центрі т  місто як
виглядає таксі ти приїжджаєш
у готель і залишаєшся в
номері дивишся у вікно спальні
що бачиш дивишся на небо
якого кольору яка погода
ти вирішив  вийдіть на прогулянку на вулицю, щоб
почати досліджувати
місто, на вулиці багато людей,
як вони виглядають, у що вони
одягнені,
ви бачите босів на вулиці, якого кольору
вони, якого кольору поштові скриньки,
ви відчуваєте голод, тому ви зупиняєтеся на
щось поїсти що ти їси ти
вирішив почати огляд визначних пам'яток
міста, де у тебе добре, дуже добре
вникнути в ситуацію,
так чи ти уявляв, що вже в
Лондоні Вау Вау о Боже, я не
знав, що у тебе таке  гіпнотичні здібності,
ти майже загіпнотизував мене, Пол,
ти все ще тут, в Україні, і маєш
урок з нами, добре, хлопці, давайте
продовжимо, які зображення представляють
для вас Великобританію, давайте визначимося з п’ятьма кращими
британськими іконами і хлопці,
будь ласка, напишіть
Я думаю, що я думаю
про монархію, звичайно, потім я думаю про
біг-бенд і я думаю про будівлі
парламенту, потім я думаю про Шотландію
і замки Шотландії і, звичайно, я
починаю думати про  Римляни приїжджають до
Англії та дають їй назву,
і я не можу не думати про
вікінгів, тож які значки для вас,
давайте подивимося, я склав список, можливо, ви погоджуєтеся
з ним чи ні Пол, перевірте мій список, будь ласка,
щоб королева тоді  dubby dubby dubby
Інтернет добре це почалося на островах,
а потім всесвітня спадщина під цим я маю на увазі
Вільяма Шекспіра театр, королеву
Єлизавету першу та її золотий вік,
королеву Вікторію та сера
Вінстона Черчілля та всі
інновації та винаходи, які
британці дали світу  потім, звісно,
маю про Гаррі Поттера, і я думаю, що ві
найвідоміший підліток у всьому св
ті, мабуть, є, і хлопці, я не
ожу не думати про паби та англійський сн
данок, я знаю Ір
андію та D  Ублін не є частиною Великої
Британії, але колись я зупинявся в цьому готелі
, і цей ірландський сніданок навіть
більший за англійський сніданок. Ну
добре, тепер, Пол, ви в Україні, і
що для вас є знаковим в Україні, і
якщо ваш британський  Прийди в Україну,
що б ти їм показав. Я б,
очевидно, зробив, мої британські
друзі цього не усвідомлюють, і я цього не
усвідомлював, тому я приїхав в Україну і
пішов дивитися шоу козаків у Заппа-Ріші,
тому що  більшість людей в
Англії, мабуть, вірять, що козаки
начебто росіяни, але тепер я розумію,
що козаки - українці, тому
для мене коштує X
О, знаковий український так, і навіть
слово двоюрідний брат означає вільну людину,
насправді ідеї свободи, які вони
завжди процвітали на річці
береги Дніпра добре, що ще,
може, очевидно, їжа кухня, то як
ви знайдете українську кухню так я здається,
я сказав раніше, я люблю низенький борщ
добре, ви любите цих зелених Борис правильно,
але як щодо червоного п  я не дуже
зацікавлений у цьому, тому що я деякий час жив у Польщі
до того, як приїхав сюди,
і у мене були польські лапи, тому моєму українському
другу я зараз не сподобаюся, але я
насправді віддаю перевагу польському босу, я бачу добре, ал
як щодо дуже унікального  і знову щось
подібне, можливо, мені не варто було
їхати до Польщі, перш ніж я приїхав в Україну,
тому що у них є щось точно таке,
як вареники, я забув, як вони
це називають, але це виглядає так само, я бачу, так що ці
кухні дуже схожі, але все одно
різні  добре, що ще
так ви згадали дві іконки, можливо, одну,
можливо, тому що я з ну а багато
гір для мене це Карпати
мм-хм потужність і регіон дійсно
є конічним для України через більше можливо,
давайте на Терещенко трансфер Янко
можливо, так,
тому поет поет відомий поет
ну ми можемо порівняти російське чанко,
я думаю, з Джеффрі Чосером, оскільки
Джеффрі Чосер вважається
батьком англійської мови, а
також трешу Савченко він я
Батько літературної української мови та
ще один у мене просто повні
небезпеки український отримав чи спроектував свій
найбільший вантажний літак
у світі так це правильно і
назва цього вантажного літака МВС що означає
сон окей, подивимося  якби я
так добре вгадав усі ваші ікони особисто, я думаю,
що кожен іноземець, який приїжджає в
Україну, має зрозуміти, що йому
потрібно побачити Київ, і, очевидно, я живу в
Києві, але я мав би сказати чи не погодитися,
що Київ - найкраще місто  в Україні
для мене viv найкращий в Україні
ладно так, неодмінно тримай de vivre а
потім, можливо, додай essa щоб побачити Чорне море
добре вони зберегли Афіни
це просто без сумніву
літак Бріа і негр і козаки
добре чи можете ви мені нагадати  ходив туди я
не можу згадати назву як
називається острів у головній ролі в цій
операції де козаки походять
від назви острова Орта дитина
так і національна кухня так що п'ять
іконок для го  e Британців побачити в Україні,
хлопці, давайте йти далі,
добре, ви добре з цифрами так, я можу
порахувати пальці на моїй руці добре, я можу
ви порахувати ваші пальці не в той же час, як
мої пальці, ви можете додати ці два пальці,
можливо, ми, можливо, можливо  добре скільки
пальців у тебе пальців немає більшість
українців скажуть десять а у нас
вісім тому що у нас є великі пальці великі чи
ні пальці правильно я думав, що
зможу вас зловити але все одно не навчаю
Україну стільки років я розумію,
що українці рахуються  ферми як пальці
так, хлопці, насправді у нас чотири
пальці тут
і чотири пальці тут, а це
великий палець, тому додайте пальці два великих пальця і десять па
ьців на ногах, добре, а тепер приходьте, Пол, чи можете ви, бу
ь ласка, прочитайте числа, у вас все до
ре, уд
чі 60  у нас знову 60 ми маємо 250 ми маємо
50 маємо 116 і дев'ять і дев'ять добре,
тепер завдання полягає в тому, щоб заповнити пропуски
цими числами, давайте прочитаємо речення
і придумаємо, а потім побачимо
відповіді, тому першого більше ніж  хто
лангу  у Лондоні говорять про віки, твій
гість, Пол добре, як я прожив у Лондоні
більшу частину свого життя. Я знаю, що в
Лондоні одна з найрізноманітніших культур серед
усіх міст світу, і нещодавно я прочитав,
що 25% населення
не  корінні, що означає, що вони не
з Лондона, тому це має бути дуже велике
число 100 або більше, це більше 100 або 250,
добре, тому давайте введемо два варіанти:
250 і 100 добре, тоді більше, ніж скільки
відсотків дітей середньої школи в
Англії  не мають англійської як
рідної мови,
ви сказали, що Лондон – це плавильний котел
різних культур, так, і, як я вже сказав, 25
% не є корінним населенням, отже, 25% у
нас немає 25%, ймовірно, 16, ймовірно, 16
добре, тоді настає  населення
Сполученого Королівства майже мільйони
скільки так, це легко 60 60
добре, і населення Англії
дуже добре Англія, очевидно,
найбільша з чотирьох країн,
значно найбільша,
найбільша, тому якщо ми скажемо
по  населення шістдесят, це, ймовірно, 50,
ймовірно, добре, давайте подивимося, тоді у Британії
більше людей у віці старше, ніж менше, тому це
ва до та
, вони мають бути як екстремальні чи
ла так, як найнижчі та на
вищі так, не найвищі 250 на
вищі так, але, можливо, дев'ять  і шістдесят,
можливо, одного дня лондонці залишать до
250 ну я збираюся жити до ста
, добре, наступного
валютою Великобританії є фунт, і
я точно знаю цю, тому я знаю,
що 100 пенсів становлять один фунт  так, і я
знаю, що 100 екземплярів роблять одну гривну
, це так, але так цікаво,
що штани все ще використовуються, але
ви не використовуєте іншу валюту, яку ви
раніше мали, як стелі о так, так,
але ми не користуємося  думаю, що вони перестали заробляти
копійки, тож найгладший із них, мабуть, -
це пісячи, можливо, найменший коштує навіть 5 пенсі,
тепер я бачу добре, тому, хлопці, давайте подивимося
правильні відповіді, а
в Лондоні розмовляють понад 250 мовами, це
дуже велика кількість, яку я можу»
навіть не уявляю  скільки початкових Мелетів
живе в Лондоні, так, і ми повинні
пам'ятати, що, оскільки Лондон, столиця
Англії, Співдружності та
Співдружності, у нас багато громадян
із Співдружності, особливо з цього
субконтиненту Індії, і, як ми знаємо, в
Індії вони мають тисячі мов,
так  добре, а потім 9% дітей середнього
шкільного віку або більше не володіють
англійською мовою на своїй першій мові, це означає,
що в їхніх сім'ях вони розмовляють
іншою мовою, так, добре, що створює
проблему для адміністрації школи,
і я пам'ятаю свою школу, яка не була  Я не
так розлютився на більший відсоток, але в моїй
школі, коли батьки надходили додому листи,
вони були різними мовами
мм-хм, ось це
дійсно може бути проблемою, насправді добре,
тоді населення Сполученого
Королівства становить майже 60 мільйонів.  думаю, що
це більше шести мільйонів, можливо,
близько шістдесяти трьох або чотирьох, зараз добре,
і це дуже цікаво, що
населення Англії тільки закінчилося  r 15
мільйонів, тому тому що люди виправляють мене, якщо
я помиляюся, але з Шотландії п'ять
мільйонів свердловин формально,
я думаю, Північна Ірландія два мільйони,
так, цікаво, що багато
людей зосереджено в Англії
і з цих 50 мільйонів у районі Великого
Лондона  це не сам Лондон, але
район Великого Лондона, включаючи всі
передмістя, становить 12 мільйонів, тому ви можете
дивитися нашу математику, ніби майже 25
відсотків Англії живуть десь
поблизу Лондона, а у Британії
більше людей у віці старше 60 років, ніж до 16, це
не так.  насправді дуже гарна ідея, але
я вважаю, що зараз це досить поширене
в більшості європейських країн, тому що
ви знаєте, що ми живемо здоровіше,
ми не вмираємо так молоді досягнення в
медицині, але я згадую нещодавно, з
сумом, через коронавірус в Італії
це країна з найстарішим
населенням, як я бачу, добре, і я був цілком
правий щодо кількості штанів в одному
фунті 100 добре, хлопці, ми готові рухатися
далі, і ми збираємося прочитати текст a  і
обговорюйте питання, щоб я побачив
слова, які Пол дійсно обожнює, це
футбол і їжа разом,
футбол і їжа добре, тому ми збираємося
читати про різноманітне суспільство, футбол
, їжу та життя в Англії, тому я
почну читати, чи  Будь ласка, слідкуйте за мною,
де
Англія, можливо, країна, про яку більшість
людей спочатку думають, коли думають
про Сполучене Королівство, вона межує з
Шотландією та Уельсом, і там проживає майже 50 мільйонів
людей, що становить понад 80%
загальної кількості населення Великобританії,
включаючи великі міста  Лондон, столиця
Бірмінгем перемішав Лідс Ньюкасл і
Манчестер Лондон є одним з
найвідоміших міст у світі, і для
багатьох є представником всієї
Англії, якщо не всієї Великобританії,
всі ікони включають футбольних акторів Джуда
Лоу та Кейт Вінслет
Паби та пиво Bridget Jones, але, перш за все, це
представляє всю Великобританію, а не лише
Англію.
народився чи зараз проживаючи тут,
коментував, що було дуже важко
розрізнити англійську та британську
культуру та ідентичність. Люди виявили, що
вони часто ототожнюють себе більше з іншими
речами, ніж з Англією як країною,
ці інші речі включають місце чи
регіон, у якому вони живуть, де б вони не були
бути великим містом або одним з англійських
округів, наприклад Йоркшир Девон
Нортумберленд, Великобританія в цілому або
релігійною чи етнічною спільнотою, з якої вони походять
, добре, тому ми читаємо текст зараз, давайте
обговоримо деякі питання, тому Пол,
яка зазвичай перша країна  люди
думають, коли чують слово Сполучене
Королівство, звісно, більшість людей думають про Ан
лію, однак, тому що я живу в Уельсі, я д
маю про Уельс, добре, так, але все одно в Ук
аїні, коли ми кажемо, що я вивчаю англійську, вони ка
уть, чи був ти коли-небудь в Англії і на
правді ти  можливо, ви ніколи не були в
Англії, але ви були в Шотландії, так,
або Уельсі, або в Північній Ірландії, і
це цікаво, яка різниця
між Англією  і
Велика Британія, хлопці, ви пам’ятаєте, що це
було з самого першого уроку, добре, тому
Пол ще раз сказав нам різницю
між Англією, Сполученим Королівством та
Великобританією, так, найпростіший спосіб
пояснити це, очевидно, Англія є однією
з чотирьох націй  оскільки Сполучене Королівство
– це країна і складається з чотирьох
країн Англія – найбільша держава
у Сполученому Королівстві Сполучене Королівство –
це політичний термін Великобританія більш
географічна мм-хм, і я знаю, що
Велика Британія – це більший острів, правий
і  Велика Британія — це назва
самої країни. Добре, хлопці, чи відвідували ви чи
хтось із ваших однокласників будь-яке
з міст, згаданих у тексті, чи були
ви коли-небудь у Бірмінгемі чи
були в Лідсі. Я хороші друзі, які живуть
у Лідсі та  вони там дуже щасливі,
так, Пол, що б ти порадив нам
відвідати не тільки Лондон, звичайно, добре, якби
мені довелося вибрати один, якщо ви турист,
і туристичні місця, якщо я h  Я можу
вибрати одне місце, воно не в Лондоні, воно
моє улюблене, тому, якщо я беру людей,
щоб показати місця, які я завжди
рекомендую побачити, це Стоунхендж,
добре, які відомі мої
улюблені пам'ятники відвідати, це настільки
історичне, що це дуже старо,
ви знаєте, що всі ходять  про
єгипетські піраміди, частини Стоунхенджа
давніші, ви знаєте, і це схоже на таємницю, яку
ніхто не знає, не може зрозуміти чи
зрозуміти, як вони переміщують ці камені
деякі з них 600 тонн 600 тонн без
автомобілів або щось подібне, як вони
переміщують їх сотні  кілометри, це
як дивовижне те саме, що і піраміди,
звісно, але це дивовижно, і це кр
сиво, і ти можеш ходити навколо нього, і це
правді справді таємниче, я се
йозне і красиве місце, добре, але як
о говорити про міста, мм-хм, то
кщо  щоб знати про вас, що ви
футбольний фанат, тож, у яке місто ви
б нас повезли, очевидно, у
Лондоні є близько 15 футбольних команд, добре,
хлопці, давайте рухаємося далі, а Пол, я знаю, що
ви жили  Лондон давно,
так, це дуже цікава річ
з Лондона насправді, тому це
римований сленг кокні, тож чи можете ви розповісти нам трохи
про це, ви б не повірили
цьому, але це приклад, Адам і Єва, ви
б не повірили,
добре так  римований сленг кокні схожий на те, що
спочатку він прийшов із підземного світу
і був розроблений як мова, тому
поліція не могла зрозуміти, що
говорять злочинці, а кокні — це
особливий район Східного Лондона, і
ніби він насправді не вживається так часто, зараз
це досить  старомодний, і він просто
використовується в дуже дуже маленьких передмістях, але він
ніби римує слова
зі справжнім значенням так, і я
пам'ятаю в літературі, як Еліза
Дулітл, прямо зі сцени шоу,
вона бідна кокні так, і
намір професора Хіггінса полягав у тому, щоб  навчіть
її розмовляти англійською, як середній клас, так,
добре, і, як уже сказав Пол, це
секретна кодова мова, і дві
теорії полягають у тому, що її придумали
в'язні, які хочуть  d спілкуватися
один з одним без того, щоб охоронці
розуміли, або що ринок Landers
винайшов це, щоб мати можливість говорити без
того, щоб клієнти їх добре розуміли,
все одно це мова коду, але тепер ми
можемо розважатися з нею,
як давайте подивимося, як це працює,
взявши  пара пов'язаних слів, наприклад,
перегони на човнах, щоб ці слова поєднувалися,
а друге слово римувалося зі словом, яке ви
хочете приховати, тож подумайте, що обличчя гонки, ви
можете використовувати лише перше слово,
пов'язане з парою, щоб посилатися на слово, яке
ви хочете  сховайте або ви можете використати
пару слів, наприклад, у неї є
гарний човен, і ви маєте на увазі, що вона
має гарне обличчя іноді і може
бути одним словом, яке воно просто римується, або
вся фраза насправді добре, давайте подивимося
на груші, тож яблука та груші
означає сходи так, тож ми говоримо, що я йду,
якщо я лягаю спати ввечері, я
б сказав: на добраніч я підійду на
яблука та груші так, добре, а Пол, чи можеш
ти дати мені свого собаку так, це точно
правильно,
добре  ми б дійсно сказали, чи можу я мати
собаку та кістку, ми щойно скоротили це собака,
ви знаєте, це означає, що я прошу вас
дати мені свій телефон, добре, і задихається, ви
не хотіли б,
Адам і Єва, це означає, що ви
не б  вірю,
добре, цікаве від мене ковбаса
та пюре означає готівку, так,
наступний буханець хліба означає капелюх
так, знову ж таки, ми б не використовували другу
частину, ми говоримо, якби хтось був не дуже
розумний, він не працював над питанням
виходь або дайте відповідь на те, що ви хотіли відповісти,
ви можете сказати, давай, вам потрібно використовувати
свій буханець ага,
тому вам потрібно використовувати свою любов, щоб правильно розв’язувати
математичні завдання, а потім ви принесете
хліб і починаєте шити так, так,
або ви використовуєте свою голову, це зазвичай  наприклад,
скажи негатив, якщо хтось не думає,
використовуй свою любов я бачу, добре,
гм, мені подобається ця печена картопля, побачимось
пізніше
щось інше ні не будинок  так,
Міккі Маус, як і багато з них,
дійсно модернізувався, ми, як
ви знаєте, з мовою або всіма
меншинами, які змішуються в Лондоні, тому Міккі
Маус тепер має тенденцію бути підробкою, якщо хтось
намагається продати мені щось, це не так,
як справжні годинники Cartier  якщо ви знаєте, що це
не ви сказали б, що це Міккі Маус або
хтось розповість вашу історію, не вірте,
що це Міккі Маус, це фейк, це
казка, я бачу добре, хлопці, він бачив, що
мова розвивається кожна людина, яка
використовує мову, використовує її по-
різному  або навіть деякі нові слова можуть з'явитися
в словнику, наприклад, слово в
Google, так, так, просто введіть його в Google,
так, так, це пошукові системи так,
добре, а не тільки пошукова
система Google добре, хлопці, давайте продовжимо, зараз
ми в Англії, і ми"  перебуваючи в Англії,
чи не побачили б ви наведені нижче місця, якими ми
подорожували, заблуканими по Лондону, але, можливо,
ви знаєте щось більше про
Великобританію та її території, тож ми маємо
ці міста Кембридж Манчестер
Лі  verpool Бірмінгем Йорк
Стратфорд-на-Ейвоні, Оксфорд і -
осередок Данії дуже простий,
землі й молоді, і у нас є ці
цікаві місця, тому в перший день
будинку Бітлз ми вже згадували це,
так, це велике місто на північному заході
з Великобританії, і це Ліверпуль, добре, хлопці, так
що другий – рідне місто над
Шекспіром, так, першим був
Ліверпуль, а другий –
Стратфорд-апон-Ейвон, і кажуть, що
Вільям Шекспір народився там, до
ре, а наступне, що Оксфорд і Ке
бридж  чому ці міста такі відомі
в усьому світі, вони є двома
провідними університетами в усьому світі
і одним із найстаріших університетів, так,
а найстарішим з цих двох є Оксфорд,
так, добре, і в них є
гонки на човнах правильно  хвилі на Темзі
Патні в Лондоні зазвичай квітень, але
мені пощастило, тому що
цього року коронервірус скасовано, я бачу добре,
наступне місце - Бірмінгем, це
друге місто в Ен
я вважаю, що для мене сьогодні ввечері населення після Лондона,
і це дуже відоме в автомобільній
промисловості, не так вже й зараз ми не
виробляємо чи виготовляємо так багато автомобілів в
Англії, але раніше було дуже
зайнято виробництвом автомобілів, я знаю, що  це одне
з найбільших промислових міст, і
насправді його іноді називають
серцем Англії, тому що він знаходиться в
центрі країни, і я також прочитав
це, що в Бірмінгемі більше каналів,
ніж у Венеції, насправді,
можливо, не так романтично, але безумовно
більше каналів у Бірмінгемі у Венеції
, це цікаво, добре, тож приходить
Йорк. Я люблю це місто через його
історію, для мене воно справді стародавнє
через вікінгів, а
Драккар приходить до Йорка і бореться з цими
саксами, тому Пол, які твої уявлення про
Йорк  Yoke
має величний чудовий собор, який ви
можете побачити на задньому плані
Йоркський собор так, Вестмінстерське абатство виглядає гарно,
але Йоркський собор дивовижний,
куди вам точно варто відвідати, якщо хочете  Йорк, ти
маєш підійти до свого міністра, так, так
, приходять землі, і тому, коли ви
досягаєте каналу, ви думаєте, що земля,
але насправді ми знаємо, що це
не кінець землі, але для
людей, які жили на островах, вони
вважали, що це кінець світу,
це найдальша точка на південний захід,
є більш південна точка, яка називається ящер-
пойнт, але це найбільш
південно-західна точка Великобританії, і є
багато відомих особистостей, які роблять благодійні
прогулянки від цієї точки, південно-західної
точки, тому протилежна точка  це Шотландія
, місце під назвою Джон О'Гроутс,
тому люблять приїжджати з півдня на саму
північ, вони зазвичай йдуть іншим шляхом, щоб
йти з півночі на південь з півночі на
південь, і вони проводять благодійні прогулянки, і я
думаю, що це 800 миль.  понад
тисячу кілометрів 800 миль або
тисячу кілометрів це як від Києва
до кордону з Угорщиною
це довга прогулянка це дуже відоме
благодійними прогулянками або благодійною благодійністю їздою
на бі  ke,
я бачу добре, наступна ваша
улюблена солена гра, так, і
Стоунхендж, ви багато про це говорили,
добре, а потім приходить Манчестер
Манчестер так,
тому я знаю Манчестер з Манчестер
Юнайтед і Манчестер Сіті так, так,
так, і також має кілька хороших університетів
так, менеджер Манчестер Юнайтед,
улюблені сорокові, але в Манчестері є ще
чотири або п'ять футбольних команд, про які
люди не знають, так, і
насправді ця годинникова вежа виглядає
як Великий вибух, так, це не великий
бамбук, так, але дуже
схожий на  Манчестер — дуже індустріальне
місто, схоже на лідерство в індустріальній
еволюції. Манчестер і Лідс мали так
багато заводів і фабрик, ніби
не столицею Лондон був столицею, але
індустріальна еволюція багато людей переїхали
з Лондона на північ, тому що саме
там були всі фабрики.  так,
іди домашнє завдання буде для перших 100
дуже швидких користувачів Kahoot. Я призначу
цей Kahoot і першу сотню
студенти зможуть пройти через це
та пограти в неї з нами,
тому питання стосуються теми
тюремної сітки, вони підсумовують все, про що
ми говорили протягом останніх 10
уроків, я сподіваюся, що ви матимете час
і весело грати в цю гру добре, хлопці
Британія велика, ніхто не може заперечити, що
Ольга так правдива, тому я сподіваюся, що одного разу ми
зможемо відвідати цю країну, і ми
попросимо Пола провести нам екскурсію, я
буду гідом для всіх, добре, тому ловіть його
за його  слова добре, хлопці, це
кінець уроку, сподіваюся, що вам сподобалося з нами,
бачу, ви чудово проводите час, до побачення
[Музика]